social media seems to be tearing us
apart at the same time absolutely ask
any lawyer any in any City anywhere in
the world what the number one reason
that they are handling a divorce and
they will tell you Facebook the number
one reason let that be an indication of
the things to come and people say oh
well I'll use Twitter or I'll just
anonymously use Tik Tock or these other
silly Services they're entertaining and
should not be used for more than 10
minutes a day but people spend hours and
hours on these things yeah when is the
last time that you can find someone
under 30 years old that spent most of
their time outside speaking to other
people rather than looking at a a glass
[Music]
slab